[音楽]
私は大学で植物の研究をしています
大学では日々最先端の科学が進められてい
ますが
その中で私は農業では最も古い技術の一つ
である接ぎ木の研究をしています
そう
最も古い技術を最も新しくする挑戦です
杉木という言葉
皆さんも学校の生物の時間などどこかで
聞いたことがあるのではないでしょうか
接ぎ木とは2つの植物を一つにつなぐ技術
です
そうして一つの植物として育てる技術で
一般には根っこにあたる部分と地上部の
部分をつなぎます
この次木
何のためにするのでしょうどんな場面で
使われているのでしょう
おそらく
この会場にいるほとんどの皆さんが生起さ
れた職別を見たり
追記された植物から採れる果実を食べて
いるんです
例えば
春に咲く桜の木
この綺麗な桜の木
ソメイヨシノは
全国すべての木が次によってその数を
増やされています
同じように
リンゴやナシブドウといった多くの果物の
木が接ぎ木によってその数を増やされてい
ます
接ぎ木は
野菜を育てるときにも使われます
土からくる病気を防ぐために使われるん
です
日本では食卓に並ぶトマトや9位その
ほとんどが追記された苗から作られてい
ます
どうですか
このように追記は私たちの生活の一部と
言えます
さて次木ですが実はとても古くから始め
られているんです
聖書にもその存在は描かれています
2000年以上も遥か昔から現在まで実に
長い間私たちはつい気を使っているんです
驚きますよね
私も研究をはじめまではこのことを知り
ませんでした
本日は
私たちがどうして次の研究をしているのか
そして研究をすることでどんな未来を描い
ているのかそれについてお話ししたいと
思います
まずはなぜ私たちが接ぎ木の研究をして
いるのがどうして植物なのか
ちょっと真面目な話をさせてください
皆さんもご存知のように私たちは今
地球規模の環境問題に直面しています
地球温暖化です
地球温暖化は人類がその活動を活発化さ
せることによって徐々に徐々に進行してき
てしまいました
私が子供の頃
ニュースデイ
石油を燃やして二酸化炭素を発生させてい
その結果
温室効果によって
北極や南極の氷が解けてききてしまって
いること
そのせいで氷の上で暮らすシロクマだその
生活の場を追われ絶滅の危機に瀕している
ということを知りました
とんでもないことが起きている
この状況がさらに深刻化すれば私たちの
安全な未来はない
私はその当時そういった危機感を持ちまし
た
時がすごすぎて大学生の頃に生物学を学ぶ
中でこの地球温暖化の問題は動物だけでは
なくて
植物にも大きな問題をもたらすことを知り
ました
植物は太陽の光を浴びてそれをエネルギー
に変えてくれる存在です
私たち動物はその植物を食べることで生き
ていますつまり
植物は私たちにとって
かけがえのない大切なパートナーです
ですから植物を守ることは私たちの生命を
守ることだと思っています
温暖化が進むと植物にはどんな影響が出る
のでしょうか
その大きな影響は植物が根を張る土に現れ
てくるんです
気温が上昇すると当然
土は乾燥してしまいます
そうすると植物の成長に必要な水が土から
失われてしまいます
同時に
土の乾燥化が進むと土の中に含まれている
塩分の濃度が上昇して塩害が発生します
他にも土が乾燥することによって風が吹く
とその土の表面が削り取られてしまう
そこにいる植物の成長を助けてくれる微
生物たちも失われてしまうといった問題が
起きます
さらに地球温暖化は最近話題になっている
大雨の頻度を高めてしまいます
大雨が流す2 project 植物の根
は腐ってしまったり
病気が蔓延したり
大雨によって地中の栄養分が流されて
しまったりします
このように地球温暖化は植物にとっていき
にくい環境を生み出してしまうのです
それではどうするのか
現在
環境ストレスから植物を守るための栽培
方法や
環境ストレスに強い食別の品種改良が
世界中で必死に行われています
ベースがそれにはどうしても時間がかかっ
てしまう
そんな中で私たちがこの問題を解決する
ために着目したのはそう
古くから私たちの社会に定着している安全
な技術
接ぎ木です
私たちが考えているのは
環境ストレスに強い植物の根っこを持って
きてい
その上に私たちが育てたい作物を接ぎ木し
て育てるというものです
自然界の中から環境ストレスに強い植物を
見つけてくればすぐに適用することができ
そうです
どうですか
簡単な発想ですよね
でも残念
いいところまでいっていうけど欲しい
そう簡単には行けません
なぜなろう
植物は
仲間同士であれば追記することができます
が仲間以外とは聖域することがとても
難しいからです
ここで
ブレイクするとなったのが
大学で県警をしている時の発見です
私たちは植物の中にはなんと次がとても
得意な植物がいるということを発見したん
です
それがこちらです
何かわかりますか
こちらでどうでしょう
そう
タバコです
こちらに
この驚くべき追記能力を初めて捉えた映像
をお示しします
タバコと菜の花の追記です
この2つの植物は全く種類の違う
植物です
にもかかわらず
ご覧のように
タバコと菜の花は接ぎ木して一緒に育てる
ことができることが分かりました
この追記ではきちんとお水や栄養が運ばれ
ていることも科学的に示しています
さらにこのタバコを他の様々な植物に追記
してみるとなんとタバコは色々な種類の
野菜や
穀物
果物の木と水紀できることがわかってきた
のです
この発見を利用して
これまでに
色や形の違う花津気屋
ちょっと変わった追記をすることができて
います
皆さんも試してみたくなりませんか
はっはっは
ここではじめの提案に戻ります
環境ストレスに強い猫の上に
作物を追記して育ったかったわけですが
この時
間に
杉木能力が優れたタバコを挟み込むことで
もともと直接追記することが難しいプチ
買った2つの植物を間接的につなぐことが
できると考えています
そして実際に
環境ストレスに強く
陸上でとても繁殖している菊の上に
タバコを挟んでトマトを追記することに
成功しました
大きな一歩です
ですが
写真にあるように
今の段階ではトマトの実は一つしか実り
ません
そのためこれからも研究を重ねていくこと
が必要です
私は研究を続けていけば
ちょっと
この厳しい環境のなかでも植物を栽培する
ことのできる有効な技術が生まれてくると
信じています
そしてそのような技術を生み出すことに
よっ
地球環境を回復し
豊かな未来を切り開いていきたいそう思っ
ています
本日ご紹介したのは接ぎ木という
私たちの考える一つのアプローチに過ぎ
ません
環境問題を解決するためのアプローチはた
ようです
必ず旬
大学で行われているような専門的な研究
ばかりではありません
この世界を救うのは
あなたの
ある瞬間の思いつきと行動です
初めはとてもシンプルなものでもいいです
あなたにとってもきっと私たちにとっての
追記があるはずです
私は
社会を変える原動力は一人一人の人間に
あると強く信じています
そしてその一人ひとりの個人が尊重されて
社会からとても大切にされる応援される
そんな社会が大事なんだと思っています
これからも
社会を豊かにするあっと驚くようないぉ
とりどりのアイディアやチャレンジがある
ことを楽しみにしていますどうも
ありがとうございました
[拍手]